That's what I was saying.
Anybody who tries to get away with a crime for example,
like this Guy Jesse,
small light or whatever,
uh,
how,
this is what I had are no staff from day one,
Bro fucking call it.
People coming to me and me and Jamie,
we shut the cameras.
Are we like is everything done by in this shit?
Fuck Jamie's like I ain't buy this shit.
I'm like,
I'm never going to say it.
Clad people texted me,
this is bullshit because you know it just sounded cal and I was like
yeah some people were saying online that it was like,
like what happens when you let actors write a script,
right,
right.
Bridget even worse,
getting an actor to try to get away with a crime.
There are cops,
Chicago cops,
cause they haven't seen everything cause they don't cause those guys don't study
crime and you're new to the game and you come and you're going to pull the wool
over the Chicago police.
All those detectives.
And it's like me,
I started fighting a little,
I saw some stuff on youtube.
I'm going to go and fight.
And how about,
how about,
how about the Brian,
his boys and they squealed real fast,
quick huggle don't need to finish it.
Fuck's going on in your phones.
I left those guys loose.
They're like,
you can move in in house like we're good here.
The guys,
he,
uh,
he hired her.
Johanna actually sculpted the right trainer.
Hector lumbar.